[Music]
what's Happ baby boy I got the Bon scad
tattoo do you really you're that [__]
oh my God you're [__] beautiful you
are [__] beautiful without that guy
I'm dead he was uh tremendous man a lot
of somebody called me the other day and
asked me who the named the the top three
frontman yeah and I brought up Bon Scott
and they're like ah he's no Freddy Mur I
go you know what oh was that Don Baris
no I go I same [__] Bon
Scott August 4th of 1979 was a young kid
opening up for 10ed N I saw the same we
Weekend Warriors at Madison Square
Garden he was amazing that's when he
went out in the audience and he [__]
did the whole thing on Ang Angus would
get on their shoulders people would lose
their that was way before the pit the
whole [__] thing stinky people
jumping up and down that was way before
that and then I saw him the next year on
Back in Black right with Brian it was
amazing it was like the guy died on my
birthday February 19th yeah and uh
[__] you know they had a new singer
and they were ready Rock I think they
were opening for Judas Priest when I saw
I mean I saw a priest I had to say
[__] 15 times yeah I saw a priest too
and I heard that when they were in town
two weeks ago they were just phenomenal
I was there oh man I couldn't believe it
there was uh I was I went because I did
the noia center two nights ago with the
two nights before with the Russell
Peters so I'm backstage and there's like
the GM so I go yeah I really want to see
priest and two minutes later they gave
me this [__] envelope with seats and
passes and [__] so I took Danny from the
store oh yeah I said we're going to
priest and we're going in [__] luxury
and man they came on and they played
like jawbreaker you know
jawbreaker [__] killing man and uh
Love Bites they did a lot of stuff off
the um Defenders of the faith record
which that's when I jumped off the bik
by that time I was bugging people by
that time it was I think I was there for
heading out to the Highway and I was
done after so they had the point entry
record that's the first entry and then
the one after that what was the one
after heading out to the highway I got
nothing to lose that was it Point entry
after solar Angels yeah I was done by
that time by that time I was way done I
was on solar Angels is amazing that's
what they used to open up with that's
they remember when they came out of the
box listen I uh it it was November I
didn't know anything about anything and
a friend of mine had a hat that
said Jesus Christ but in the Jesus
Christ it said Judas Priest right and I
go what the [__] is that and uh the next
day we were in study hall and the next
day he brought me an atack of Unleashed
in the East a and I went home and threw
that [__] on and there was I
didn't understand like I was still into
I was still in love with The Song
Remains the Same live that was it I came
home and and then by that time when this
kid Steve had given me this cassette or
a track whatever I went home and I heard
I was blown the [__]
away the
CER victim of chain just just all that
[__] Exciter and I love that stand back
from Mi oh my God so man I was really
[__] and I never told the story I was
really [__] depressed it was two
weeks after my mom died it was the week
before it was the weekend after
Thanksgiving that Saturday after
Thanksgiving and my friends are going to
go see priest you want to come and I'm
like nah and at six o'clock I go what
the [__] is wrong with you they're
playing at the Palladium yeah going to
see a band at the Palladium was like
going to the main room at the comedy
store that's what it was like going to
the main room small small they had a you
know they had 2,000 seats but you it was
a movie theater with 2,000
seats and I went over there by myself
and I got tickets for 20 bucks and I
went in and they came out of the [__]
motorcycle and that was 79 November 29th
1979 that [__] pulled off with a
motorcycle and during the center he
whipped out a whip yeah and started just
whipping the it was whipping the tank I
was I left there I didn't know what to
do and I had a little bit of blow yeah
and I took the uh bus over in those days
the bus dropped me off on Boulevard East
where I got mugged where I tried to mug
the gay guy I think he was gay he was a
pervert and he beat the [__] out of me
and I walked up that
block and I got into an altercation that
night I got into an altercation I got
into an argument with a guy about a
broad I had bumped into somebody who was
cheating yeah I bumped into a a a guy
that was cheating with a girl that was a
friend of a friend of mine and I walked
past him and I thought about it I was by
the book then like I didn't like that
[__] at all and I walked back and I went
off on her and I remember how scared I
was that I was going to fight this kid
yeah but I didn't give a [__] I called
her a [__] a [__] [__] you know
he's in [__] a bar right now working
to take you out during the week yeah and
here you are doing this and the next day
they turned it into like two days later
by the time I got to high school that
Monday they had turned it into almost
domestic violence and it really wasn't
like they was all I pushed her I didn't
push this chick I just went back and I
go you know what you should be ashamed
of yourself and you you're a [__]
[__] I mean I just I had a little I had
oh I had a little Coke left in my system
and that girl didn't talk to me for
maybe 2 years her and the guy broke up
yeah she went to the guy and told him
something different and I look went to
the guy and looked in his eye and go
this is what really happened they were
holding hands I saw them don't [__]
tell me in fact when I and I until this
day that guy that I went on is still
around and when I go back every once in
a while he post something on Facebook
type of cute and I just shut him the
[__] down he still hang out with some of
my friends name is Tommy nobody
remembers that though how like I I just
went off and then years later that dumb
chick came up to me it was cold out it
was really cold out and I had uh and she
was drinking vodka and iced tea this is
in high school this is how pissed off I
still am she lives in Fort Lauderdale
and whenever I do the Miami Improv they
threaten me that they're all going to
come down and see me and I tell them no
Christians allowed [__] you [__] and
they stop they won't come but this dummy
one night where out I just get out there
I just get out it's got to be 10 after 8
and I see her with like three other
girls and I'm with another guy and
they're like where you guys going we're
going over here and she had a bottle of
vodka and a nice tea by this time I
still hated this girl like I had at this
age I just hated you if you did
something stupid there was no I'm sorry
and I saw yeah she was done and she came
up to
me and she was like uh she said
something she was trying to be nice and
I go what's that on your jacket I didn't
know you were cheile or something and I
I did something like I didn't know you
were Che and when I walked away about 3
minutes later she threw one of the Iced
Teas on me just [__] threw it on my
new Jack and [__] I go [__] this [__] I
saw her she kept drinking and she kept
putting an iced tea on the floor by that
time the IC tea was a little Frozen and
I went behind the tiptoe and I took the
iced tea and I poured it over her
[__] head and I saw the icicles
freezing up on her head and she came
back and we didn't talk till
82 and then I see there a Coke deal de's
house and everything was all right I'm
sorry I'm sorry when you see somebody at
the de yeah once you see somebody at the
Dealer's house everything's forgiven
yeah you know what you weren't supposed
to see me here I wasn't supposed to see
you there what's up Lis at where the
[__] you been I've been here but I I
watched something you told me to watch
today I watch that Ary Lang on Howard
Stern I wanted to get your opinion on
two things first thing
was I've dealt with some people who have
been addicts in my life and a lot of
them are
masters of talking their way out of of
trying to convince people that it's not
as bad as it seems and at that point
already had only been clean for like 7
months if you look it up it's like
already I don't know heroin already does
heroin it's something it's like 30
minutes long 40 minutes long were you
I'm were you like that too could you
talk your way out of any anything really
anything and when I got in this
situation I was talking my way out just
so I could get high you have no idea
when somebody squashes your ey
like when you have plans about getting
high in somebody you have plans mhm sure
you don't want nobody to know how deep
you really are you would like just I
don't I have no musical background at
all yeah so just from someone who like
you would think oh I could talk if I
couldn't hear so I like I never thought
about that I always wondered why it was
so such a big deal sometimes if the
band's too loud you'll sing flat or
sharp you know and then it just sounds
horrible you're like this guy sounds
horrible but really they can't hear
their self does that happen in comedy is
there like you don't it doesn't matter
if you can hear yourself cuz you're not
you're not you're not going up you don't
want to [__] hear yourself you just
want to hear laugh this trying to hear
you're going up against instruments that
are in tune you know okay I'm remember
going to see
uh one my first
concerts it had to be the Rolling Stones
with forigner yeah and the singer from
forigner I forget what his name was L
grah L Graham tremendous he sounded
great live he's unbelievable at that
show I saw in whatever in the eighth
grade and then uh [__] came up there MC
Jager and they did something that I
accepted from them in the early on I was
such a yesterday I was playing ball with
Mercy yeah and I noticed that if the
ball fell out of whack Mercy didn't like
that what do you mean Mercy wanted it to
go from me to her to the mom if I threw
the ball at Mercy and she dropped it she
wouldn't allow me to pick it up again it
would just keep going she didn't want me
to throw it at it again it was really
weird she lost interest she no she was
by the book oh she was by the book and I
noticed that when I was a young kid I
was a [__] nerd to I used to drive my
mom crazy with that bu the book [__]
yeah everything in my world was about
the cop said that you're not allowed to
turn right my mom who gives a [__] what
the cops that I'm tell you know I was
one of those jerk balls and uh I went to
see the stones and there were one of the
first bands
that did not sound at all how I expected
them to sound right I like shattered
yeah you know shattered on S Night Live
you're like what the [__] is that
garbage Keith Richards is everywhere
he's high on something you know but as
the concert progressed I think they did
Wild Horses yeah and I started crying
yeah like I started crying and the other
one with the chick singing the black
chick oh uh yeah that one those two live
with the saxophone coming yeah yeah is
one of the most brilliant stuff you'll
ever see if you got a chance to see the
well the saxophone guy died he died
which was he [__] took all like when
you're [__] 13 and a guy comes out
with a saxophone you want to put a gun
to your head yeah yeah get I you know
what I'm saying I didn't where's this
[__] saxophone coming from what why
am I seeing a guy with a saxophone yeah
it's not rock it's not rock and and he
sold me him and pink foot uh you know
they they use the sacks on like uh dark
side and all that and and you're just
going like well this is [__]
incredible incredible like they turned
me around the first 20 minutes of the
stones I was on asset I was
young it was one of my early concerts I
didn't really know what to expect and by
the end when I left there I realized who
the [__] the Rolling Stones were like
all that [__] about the world's greatest
rock and roll band yeah I don't know if
that was accurate but they were up there
yeah like they they sold me on not being
perfect and then uh like the song is the
same first time I listened to that I'm
like I'm not listening to that junk no
more yeah yeah those junk leads they're
and one day I put that thing on it was
like the only thing I had to listen to
and again I saw the Brilliance that's
why when people come to me and say well
lead Zeppelin or whatever I go you know
want yes and no but I just want you to
do something before you make that
statement again listen to The Song
Remains the Same listen to the guitars
I'm like uh Dazed and
Confused and uh something else and then
get back to me you can't steal that yeah
that night couldn't be stolen and like
I've said this before I heard a great
interview if somebody could acquire it
and send it to me it was Robert Plant on
the king biscuit flower hour this is a
great radio show from the I think it's
still on is it I met the guy the guy
said this is the creator of the king
biscuit flower and I was a kid I'm not a
big radio guy I must have been bored and
I listen to Robert Plant describe the
shows at the Garden yeah and I remember
again being brought to a motion going
Jesus Christ you know I was thinking
about Dean Del this morning I was
listening to UFO oh God I love it Dr
doctor I love it oh the other one
phenomenon that's the name of the album
phenomenon yeah yeah what's the songs on
phenomenon uh I I I this I don't know
this the songs on it because 74 you know
what's the songs on phenomenon late
please phenomenon UFO 1974 it's on
YouTube let me look and it's also it's
not Dr doctor it's the other one that's
lights out no lights out it's the
beginning of lights out that's my
favorite oh my [__] God my the back
of my hairs my ears blow I put it as
loud as I can yeah all right so you want
know the tracks yeah yeah okay so their
side one is too young to know Crystal
Light Dr doctor there you go space child
and rock bottom rock rock bottom the
leads and Rock Bottom yeah it makes you
want to go and now you look at the date
you go 74 that's what Michael Shanker
was doing in 74 it's insane it's insane
they have a video up of uh of uh don
cs's Rock concert Dr doctor put it up
Lee on YouTube put on the big screen
what I search Dr doctor Dr doctor UFO
Don Kirsten's Rock concert he's got that
Flying V the long blonde hair Jesus
Christ and he's just kicked in and
nobody's got a shirt on I've never seen
nothing like this in my life nobody's
got a [__] shirt on the the bass
player is on the floor playing on his
back Pete way I'm dying Phil MOG was the
singer correct that was a singer for UFO
where did Phil MOG go after that MSG uh
no MSG was Shanker solo band which right
right but who was the first sing B no
but who was the first singer on and on
uh no in fact Victor mumusi album is his
first solo album and then it was the
second one with an and on 81 what's the
name of the show uh don kon's Rock
concert UFO Don kon's Rock concert Don
ks's Rock concert was a show late night
show when I was was growing up or Dean
that was either on on Friday or Saturday
don't I think Friday night was Don
kerser and Saturday was uh Saturday
night special or something like that I
can't remember which night it was on but
I never missed it you never missed it
guys I don't care how many drugs you did
who you were finger banging behind the
[__] school matter of fact they've
got a a box set you can buy yes yes yes
well rock or aesi yeah Richard prize
manager who shot all those specials and
later on years later he was the his one
of his jobs was The Midnight Special so
either Friday or Saturday night Don kers
was on after Saturday Night Live and no
lipsyncing and I remember that uh coming
home and seeing them
do black Black Sabbath did something
from Never Say Die oh man on uh no they
in fact they did Never Say Die what the
[__] am I [__] I love that oh my God
they did Never say
die and I thought I was going to jump
out the window I you know who house I
was at Lisi at the kid that got stabbed
a chance dragon in that we saw on the
way out Richie sidel ter that's whose
[__] house I was at he Denise Mick
was babysitting and [__] now we used to
all go over there we used to all get
tuned up and all go over there in the
eth grade whatever and [__] watch
this [__] it was tremendous it's [__]
so crazy great man they had everybody
they like you know fog hat Skinner
listen everybody yeah everybody except
Leed Zeppelin ACDC played it did they
really ACDC and also yeah look at it and
you know who else played it um kiss did
it Zeppelin never did it cuz Zeppelin
Peter Grant was genius he said they'll
play no TV no there's a video there's a
this reminds me of that do you guys have
cool rooms as kids like I I had my mom
was so I was like she was strict and I
was just a vanilla kid so it never I
never really decorated it but like
having a bong or some black lights or
some yeah vinyl post like that must have
been [__] I had all the kiss posters
and that David Lee Roth one where he's
tied up on a chain from Women and
Children First yeah that one boy that
one hung up there and uh and the kiss
one where they're dressed as army guy
the you know with the drums and the the
battle wounds the US Army all those man
another Joey Diaz story people don't
know about so my mom bought the home in
North Bergen it was a three-bedroom home
but the problem was one of the bedrooms
was a converted attic yeah that to any
of us we would jerk off all over it yeah
I didn't like it it scared me I heard
mice up there oh yeah atcts are [__]
scary so I would go down to this one in
the bedroom the the there was a bedroom
with a my mom's bedroom was a master
bedroom I had the bedet the shower the
tub the [__] the window the whole
[__] thing nice two sinks and then I
had a bathroom in the hallway but the
the bedroom I moved into whoever had the
house before was a girls room Pink
Carpet mirrors everywhere Barbie room
you know how many times people walked in
my uh room and walked into the mirror
because the mirror was it looked like a
huge room you kept The Pink Carpet I
kept The Pink Carpet I put like a little
wolf on the on the floor like this dead
wolf that was like fluffy WF somebody
gave me like a fur and I put like I had
the stereo with the speakers who I
robbed from the kid across the street
but then I became friends with him and
he wasn't allowed in my upstairs like he
would come to the living room let's
goair to music no we can't go upstairs
my mom don't let Boys in my room you got
the speakers up there I had the speakers
and the stereo up there I had like a I
had a Jimmy I had a lead Zeppelin poster
that Ray canel the guy who calls in here
the podcast I called a couple weeks ago
he had and it was Led Zeppelin on stage
but it was shot backwards oh yeah first
word on the street was that it was a
collector's item and all this [__] I had
a picture of Julius Irving SL duning
with that long one on the door remember
that one that long one there's his
Converse right there there red yeah and
he was still playing he played for the
Sixers but at that time they didn't pay
the Sixers so it was like a generic
costume that he had to wear like they
took the sixes off for the poster for
the poster hilarious and then I had the
McDonald's All-American basketball team
and I just on the floor next to this
thing I had to stack albums yeah and
what you know what what album I still
had in there I still remember having the
Beach Boys oh yeah which one round round
get around I get around one the right
around that one I still remember some of
my first 20 [__] albums yeah like the
first five or six albums were very
confusing albums I was still in the
graphs uh I told Leah joke there there
somebody me and Steve Simone You Know
Rich Richard Pride was basically the
first album I I bought like a right I
don't know if it's is It Something I
Said or the nigga's crazy right but when
he sees that he sees Jesus I knew Jesus
I met him on the railroad death pole I
told him don't go down there messing
with them Jews without no money you know
I forgot all about that line and [__] I
had that one in Bicentennial niggga and
I had them hidden yeah oh yeah they had
to be hidden and then I had I remember
having the Beatles White Album I had the
Beatles Help yeah I had
uh okay I was like a Michael Jackson
dude yeah yeah so I had the last two
Jackson albums moving violation and the
best of Michael Jackson Who Miss Pat
argued with me at that album didn't
exist the one with like the bird on the
cover the pigeon on the cover he still
has the nose he still has the black nose
that's a great [__] greatest H Alum I
still remember all these albums i i i
that room was uh and I was telling Lee
that what I would do is at night I'd
play records in my [__] bedroom but
in the daytime I had a little window I
could play them on my mom's living room
stereo which was kickass it was one of
those old school box V trollers with the
oh yeah turntable the control on the
other side the TV in the yeah remember
that like it's it's like an all one
piece [__] Furniture guys one [__]
piece of furniture like this table yeah
this is how long it was yeah are you
serious so it went from here to there
okay and it went against the wall so on
that side was the turntable yep on this
side was the control for the radio also
yeah the turntable and an a track player
and then the TV was in the Middle where
that thing is that Kevin put on there I
guarantee those things still work oh
yeah oh yeah those things will work to
the [__] end of time and I know
people who have them I guarantee if you
go on eBay oh yeah they're out there you
know garage sales they're out there and
you're absolutely right you put a needle
from today on there and it's brand new
brand [__] new yeah you know I saw a
guy Joey he did something that was so
amazing he bought one of those and he
gutted it out and then he put high-end
stuff in there so when you looked at it
it was straight 70s but then when you
opened it up it was just all this great
equipment now it was awesome man like
just rebuilt the insides with new [__]
it was killer Jesus I just remembered
something that's so sad and it was so
sad to me for a long time talking about
turntables
so the kid's name was Renee Renee was
Puerto Rican and when he was moving into
the building when he was moving into the
apart the house yeah he went to pick up
more stuff from wherever they were
moving from and we robbed the house in
mid in mid move mid move Rob so Renee
and his dad and the mother moved out of
there they were like running from credit
creditors and stuff but for some
reason the stereo was [__] weird like
the stereo was just old to me like I was
like I don't want to St no more I need
some hip to get the chicks up here to be
the cool guy on the Block and on the
corner was this place on four five
corners it's still there on appliance
place yeah and the word on the street
was you could go in there and get a fish
or
stereo I think your hands on something
no my hands on Oh that's oh it's over
there okay I'm not worried about it
which in the day a fish is Stereo Le was
like [__] tremendous this is before
blow Punk yeah people started saying oh
you have a Fisher I have a blob punk I
buy components man remember because
everybody got real cool after a while
component what happened was and this is
why I don't like a cell phone with a
camera and all this [__] on it because
once the camera break you got no phone
for some people they can't live without
a [__] camera on the phone I come old
school okay I come from the thing that
once your a track broke yeah the whole
stereo had to get thrown out because it
was connected to the [__] CD and the
cassette player yeah so here you were
with 90 [__] eight tracks what the
[__] you going to do now the eight
track's broken okay now I got to buy
albs I got the Almond Brothers live from
the Filmore e on eight track and now I
got to buy buckings so I said enough is
enough so I went down to [__] uh
Fisher whatever that
and you gave him 50 bucks down and the
whole thing came out to like 480 in
those days Lee
$480 for a 15 for a 13year old kid 14y
old kid it was like 1,000 bucks 1,200
bucks 13,500 bucks yeah for a stereo too
it's not like for something for school
and I went and I financed it and when I
hit the number I paid it all off wait
they let a 12-year-old kid finance my
mom cosigned it my mom had a cosign it
Mom that's the cosign [__] but at least
you made payments you had to walk down
there payment book they gave you a
payment book yeah and you had to walk
down there every Friday and pay the $15
like a man you know and you felt good
like this was my [__] stereo man like
this was it like I took care of this I
dusted it I cleaned the needle like this
was [__] it you know and when my mom
died I never took that stereo a like
that stereo sat in that [__] room God
knows where that stereo is today it
broke my heart cuz I had a t you know
you know when you have it tuned for you
like a you buy a turntable and after a
year or two the turntable gets to see
your your style and how you drop the
record and you learn and you get the
needle right and it's uh it was a sad it
was sad thing in my life for like three
years not having that turntable well you
know my my uh best friend they had the
morance and I told Marin this story and
it was basically the blue collar
Macintosh like Macintosh was so much
money but the morance and and my buddy's
dad bought it and he had the morance
2275 and a and a turntable a Pioneer
turntable and these speakers and we'
play high with hell on it and a couple
years back I bought a morance
2275 and it's in my house and and it and
and I always tell people they go does
what sounds good and I go whatever your
ears grew up on like you know because
your ears grew up on a sound and that's
the sound your brain remembers forever
so when I hooked this whole thing up and
I put on you know a record I was like
that's that's it that's eighth grade
right there morance morance yeah yeah
man and they had the blue lighting and
and the and the morance had the a
weighted wheel for the tuner you just
hit it it would
go you know on a ballaran and that was
like Pro the other ones you had to turn
and they're all funky this one just hit
the the wheel it
just and man I got it now in my house
weird to describe it is weird to
describe you know I became
nerdish about it that I was even buying
magazines you know me a long time Le I
don't buy magazines I was buying stereo
magazin high five mag funny I was
watching vinyl the other night on HBO
how is it vinyl is an interesting show
okay it's interesting show uh this week
they had like a slim the Family Stone
type [__] I saw the picture
Hannibal and [__] you know uh if you
like music and you like doing blow you
know and all that craziness this is the
show for you you know it's it's just I
watch it and sometimes I go what the
[__] am I watching yeah but it's
entertaining you know it's entertaining
to a [__] like me because it's me it's
my time I was a kid I all that me last
week they sang a song on there two weeks
ago that killed me the chick that
[__] ice s the with the pills with
the brother Amy wi house no Amy wi house
this is the [__] they started at
right I'm sorry oh oh so they're doing
real bands it's like uh like stories of
real stuff going on it's really weird
like the first episode is him going into
having to talk to lead Zeppelin okay and
Peter Grant is yelling on him and he's
selling the record label to the Germans
yeah and then the second episode the
Germans in the room and Peter Grant
walks in and he goes just let you know
I'm not selling I'm not I'm leaving you
guys I'm not going to be I'm not working
with Germans yeah wow I don't work with
[__] Germans they got a guy playing
Peter Grant yeah but uh he's not really
6'6 300 he's a little short and he talks
a lot he tries to redo that scene from
uh yeah you know the man's out there
with the posters he's out there selling
post blood [__] anything to the name of
he's your [__] man he's your man not
my man yeah that's uh love that scene
that's and that's like we just think
they go off on stage like right now
Sabbath is on tour and because of their
age they do a show and they take a show
off yeah they do a show you know in the
' 80s if you went to a con in the 70s
and the 60s these guys did four or five
nights a week nobody knew about taking
care of your throat you had witch Tails
wit is that what they call like you know
gargo with salt and honey oh yeah which
yeah you know stories about the road old
school remedies but when you find a real
singer who takes care of themselves like
really like no smoking know this you
know they really put a scarf around
their neck you don't know how much work
goes into being a [__] singer you
know when you do Coke it destroys your
throat completely destroys your throat
you hear it as you're talking do two
lines of coke there certain purple that
will come to you after a few years and
go I know when you're on coke because
your voice changes totally what happens
to it it changes you get a drip couple
lines and it and numbs your voice numbs
your vocal course so all those dudes
that did tons of blow while they sang
supposedly that's that that's why I'll
tell you what I'll tell you who had a
great voice I never saw him when he had
a great voice when by the time I got to
see him his voice was shot over the
years he's brought it back and that's
Chris Cornell oh yeah not the [__]
slaves and bulldozers back no but it's
he keeps it at a moderate level then you
learn the tricks totally then you learn
the singer tricks how to do smaller
places you change the songs around to a
lower voice well does it just start
going or is it is it can it just go can
you just wake up one day and not have a
voice anymore you it can completely go
if you don't um warm up you got to warm
up and as I went to the vocal uh doctor
a couple days ago I I've been singing
like all my life you got to warm up if
you don't warm up it's exactly like
going and playing football in the NFL
you're going to pull stuff and [__] and
what happens is it just get shot and
tired you know and and even with
podcasting and doing comedy we're
talking for hours and hours and hours
which is you know when you're in regular
job or whatever you just talk to your
co-worker like yeah I was at a party and
then you're working and you talk but
we're talking for hours you know and and
then imagine singing for a couple hours
then you're fired up you get off stage
and you're on the tour bus talking talk
talk talk talk talk you got AC going
it's drying out your voice and uh and
then you're not getting proper sleep
you're eating like [__] and next thing
you know and you add alcohol oh it dries
out your voice booze to the [__]
content cuz see it's tough enough doing
that [__] once you add the alcohol and
the booze and the bad food and the No
Sleep Jesus [__] Christ over that's
it it's over and that's basically the
life you have to lead y that's basically
let's in 200 4 and three when I went
let's just say to Houston I got to
Houston on a Tuesday
okay the week started on Wednesday
through Sunday you did all [__] one
two 4 six seven seven or eight shows you
know that's eight hours I ate like [__]
you know I didn't sleep cuz I did blow
out of the seven nights I did blow five
nights so my sleeping was uninterrupted
you know that takes a toll you know
talking to people not sleeping eating
greasy food not doing vitamins not even
breaking a sweat the only time I would
break a sweat in those days when I was
snorting coke it was like new po New
Coke was pushing out the old Coke that's
it I had new Coke pushing out the
[__] old Coke you know opening up the
pores yeah you really can't uh
eventually you get sick yeah another
thing you get sick man another thing
that people do wrong and they never know
this but you know when you hear people
clearing their throat all the time where
they're going yeah that's the worst
thing you can do for your voice cuz it
bangs the vocal cords together and as
you keep doing that the banging together
creates like a callus which is known as
a vocal node and that thing gets rock
hard and then you can't sing anymore so
these guys are constantly clearing their
throat it's just going bang bang bang
that's why a lot of singers drinking tea
they're using uh Ras and stuff to keep
their voice you know lubed so whenever I
feel something weird in my throat
instead of doing that I would just drink
some water or something and it'd be you
know you're fine but every time you
clear your throat you're banging the
vocal cords together and it's the worst
thing you can do it's crazy you know
it's great to talk to somebody I love
music but I'm not a musician right so I
really don't know I can't have any
justification at any level the [__] I
talk about music but when I talk to you
it's so weird the other day I spoke to
you and I got off the phone with you and
I was so happy to talk to you the other
morning
because I live vicariously through you
yeah I was telling my friend last week I
had a like break it down to I go a vills
his name is a villain I go vills listen
you're my brother and I love you to
death let me tell you what's going on
with me what's going on with me is I
love concerts and I love music I never
stopped loving music it was the concert
experience yeah that got on my nerves
for a while you know what I'm saying the
last few concerts I went to I see where
it became money oriented it's like I
tell people now today I love doing
standup but this part of standup I
[__] can't stand yeah I can't stand
going to town and having to count chairs
and you know selling she seats and I
hate all that [__] I just want to do
comedy and 98% of bands that get into it
at the end of the day they'll tell you
listen I don't give a [__] if I live in
a basement under a basement and never
have any money I just want to play music
just that high I would sacrifice all
that family 401k to just play live music
that's the same thing that happens us a
comic it you know you you do it one day
and you're like you know what I'm
quitting my day job and people like well
how you going to live how you going to
pay lee rent yeah you know we'll figure
it out it's 410 a month yeah that's
$1250 that's
$102.50 a week I'll find that on the
street I'll find that on the street I
can sneeze that [__] saying you can you
could sneeze that [__] it's it's it's
really crazy how you I was at a light
today and I was like wow you know
I never knew that I would do what I'm
doing with comedy today like I never
knew I never really knew but then at the
light I was like who the [__] was I
kidding that's why I made the moves I
made because you had that certain
confidence to jump into it but anyway
with all all that [__] I was thinking
about you told me your itinerary for the
week yeah and you were talking about you
were going to go see this band you going
to see the who you're trying to scal
tickets do I know anybody who's got a
ticket connection for the who you're
going to see somebody else and it's like
I live through you vicariously I have
two friends that are musicians three of
them one guy still goes to shows he's a
great musical guy but when he goes to a
show he thinks about it too much oh and
it drives me crazy but I can't lie to
you I have the same thing yeah you know
what I'm saying when I go to a show I go
to be critical you know like half of me
is critical like the singer first couple
times I went to a show a live show was
Ted nent AOL Smith Frank Marino oh yeah
and I went to see something else and I
remember that both times I left upset
even when I went to see the stones the
first time with Foreigner Foreigner was
Exquisite yeah Foreigner did the songs
how they were played on the album so
Foreigner did everything to the tea when
I went to see the stones they were
completely different than what they were
doing there were some songs like uh you
know that ballads like uh Beast of bird
and [__] like that that were to the
money couple little off takes but
shattered and a couple other songs are
completely different than when I was
used to I didn't like that too fast yeah
the only band I like that did that was
lead Zeppelin right and The Song Remains
the Same they took those songs and they
switched them around and if you you're
like what the [__] is this but I the
reason why I'm talking to you about
singers is because sometimes you hear a
band on your album and you go see the
singer live and you're like oh my
[__] god this is God awful yeah yeah
this is God awful they had a lot of
Studio [__] in his [__] voice you
know yeah well I mean you you spoke
about uh last week I forget the name of
the awards but Britney Spears lip
syncing yes what would you prefer as a
fan go to a show and see someone lip
syncing or go and see someone who just
can't oh I want it horrible if it's
going to be horrible I don't want fake
you know that's why I'm there to see
live I'm there to see a live concert and
it's a it's a lot like uh like racing or
uh you know Motocross or something it's
either going to be spectacular it's
going to be a crash you know but that
but that's the live feeling of like oh
my God I saw those guys and the third
song The the guitar player was just
wasted you know whatever it is back in
the day now it's it's it's business now
it's business the reason why I was so
mad last week watching that
League was because a I took time out of
my day to watch that [__] and it smacked
me in the face and number two and my man
he'll oh I saw priest more than anybody
growing up like I went to see him a lot
like out of all the other bands I saw DC
three or four times but priest for some
reason we always ended up going yep and
out of all those times I went to see him
in 81 82 and he sang solar Angels oh I
love it and he sang it from the side
yeah and he sang it from the side and I
was real close to him and believe it or
not I could hear the energy from his
voice I could hear the the last flowing
particles of his energy from his voice
and I was blown away when I think of
Music since I'm not a huge music guy I
think all that matters to me is the
music how important were those other
aspects the the costumes the the stage
like how important was that to you as a
fan sounds like it was a lot very
important no at that time uh I walked
out of toll oh yeah when I saw him play
the flute yeah flute Rock I you know I I
I walked out of a few movies by that age
and the guy I hung with at the time I
still hang with him he's my daughter's
guy you know he uh he doesn't have
patience for that [__] you know he never
really was a PT smoker he did acid and
went home and had a freak out at his
house you know he never really liked
that [__] so it wasn't his that's why I
kind of dug him it wasn't really always
my scene either right there was some
nights I just want to smoke a joint and
just go out and he and I went out with
him and went to you know some of our
friends went to see Twist's sister let's
go down there we we walked in and they
came out and said Twisted [__] sister
man and they had makeup on I think
during the first song we just looked at
each other and Tapped Out wow there's an
incredible document documentary yeah on
Netflix about how nobody wanted them and
they just it was just [__] one thing
yeah after the other one thing after the
other a friend of mine was explaining
and saying they become in the tri-state
area before they were even a record
dealing famous they started making
thousands on the bar circuit on their
own no one would give them a record deal
or anything so they're like [__] all you
guys man and they just selling out
everything all over the place and and
eventually become the Kings man and I
think that's around 84 that that stay
hungry record and and uh D Snider wrote
all that stuff and [__] man that guy
you know he had a vision they were way
into New York Dolls and I never got into
the New York Dolls you know and that was
their thing New York Dolls with some
kiss you know and I like to kiss but not
New York dos but Twisted Sister boy
there was a time they were the biggest
ban in the world with that I want to
run that [__] thing with that guy in
the video what do you want to do with
your life that was 84 was it I think so
yeah all right Dean when you when you
were in a band and I guess you guys are
both comedians so it's might be the same
when when you are get to that Pinnacle
of like you're the biggest in the world
do you think you think it's going to
last forever or do you do you think even
like if they like all you always hear
about one hit wonders do you think they
know like all right this is probably
like only like do you think they prepare
for it or do you think they're just
delusional the whole time well I think
that um if it's so [__] hard it's a
zillion to one to get where some of
these bands got and you got to know that
you can only be there for so long now if
you're delusional you're just all on
drugs or whatever but uh D Snider is a
very smart man and he parlayed that into
what are we looking at 30 [__] years
right now on a band that probably people
thought would last you know a week you
know so to me that is still they've made
it in my eyes if you go out you could
sell out like theaters and [__] right
now 30 years later oh yeah that like
that doesn't sound like they failed at
all how many bands got a record
deal taped the first album and fell
apart you have no idea Le the story
stories of this the same stories that go
with
comedy nobody knows you see Gabriel
laces why do you think gabri glaces
every night it's a picture of him in a
theater with people nobody goes out in
the road like Gabriel and if you talk to
gab he'll tell you the same thing this
ain't going to last forever yeah I'm
going to get a piece of this he's very
smart about it he knows exactly there's
some people that go into then you have
people that go into with their 20s
everything falls apart when they're 30
nobody knows who they are and they still
walk around with that [__] attitude
now that's crazy right you know who I am
you know who I am that's [__] crazy
you had 10 years of that like why
wouldn't you yeah like I I almost you
almost understand why it happens music
comedy
acting it takes a certain thing not to
fall apart and some people are falling
apart britley Spar fell apart for
[__] two years and came back the
little chick the Disney chick Cyrus she
fell apart for two years and somebody
had to pull her aside and talk to her
yeah uh this C
Justin Bieber Bieber whatever everybody
has a point you know gunam roses I
remember gunam roses on National
Television on heroin ndd smoking a
[__] cigarette at the podium like
they didn't give a [__] yeah that's my
when I think of Guns and Roses I think
of that that's how big they [__] were
like they were walking around [__] up
l i mean drooling heroin blow alcohol in
that breath cigarettes in a [__]
building that said no cigarettes we
don't give a [__] what Guns and Roses
yeah we're sparking you you know what
I'm saying you want to give me a ticket
you want to arrest me it don't matter
we'll be on an hour in an hour you know
so there's a certain mind thing that
goes with it well you probably have to
have that certain mindset to get to that
level I would assume look at a Axel Rose
went off the deep Bend how long did he
disappear for yeah [__] years 13 years
15 years he went to Arizona and was
living with a guy that was reading
stones to him and [__] remember you read
that Rolling Stones I mean Lee you God
knows where your mind goes can you
imagine anywhere your go girl wants to
suck your dick you go to that restaurant
for breakfast that waitress she wants to
suck your dick her kid loves you the
band you know she'll do anything for her
I mean that's just one of the perks
there's no I can't man there's no manual
yeah you know we have I would love for
for you know they talk about all this
virtual reality I would love to go and
hang with Zeppelin In 73 for 6 months
that'd be great right and see how long
it would take you to go to rehab oh yeah
how long would it really take you till
you went to rehab you [__] [__]
these people I think they go off the
deep end John bonam died in 79 that
party started in [__] since he was
three he was drinking like that and
playing the drums and your blood
pressure you know that that thing
doesn't
stop it's crazy man it's like I was
talking to you about that Blind Melon
you know uh it's like here's this band
that had they put a record out it flops
totally and then MTV starts showing the
Bumblebee video you know like hey this
is a cute video and in in a thre Monon
period they flop to three million
records like they they they think
they're done and they [__] crush it
then the singer gets on [__] drugs
and and he can't break it he can't
[__] break loose they're sending him
to rehab they're trying to [__] help
him they're trying to fix him he writes
a second record which is Monumental to
me like this record is crushing he dies
three months later I saw him a week
before he died you know and it's like it
had to just spin him out like you got to
think like you're from Indiana like he
knows Axel he sells three million
records he's living in Hollywood in the
80s 90s people are in the Don't Cry
video at the end in the Don't Cry video
at the end was that not him yeah that's
him and uh you know they were like they
were like Almond Brothers meets Jane's
Addiction and this guy's lyrics were
deep man I was reading him today cuz he
died Saturday 31 years ago I was like
this guy 31 31 years ago no or 20 21
sorry yeah
95 21 years ago um but it's just crazy
to think like how people you know they
just you I don't know what grabs you you
know you're just out there party and the
next thing you know it grabs you and
you're gone you
know you can't you know you look at
Spring Sting's longevity you look at the
stones long J don't tell me the stones
didn't have [__] problems oh man you
know they had internal problems and drug
problems look at Aros Smith oh man Le
Aros Smith take Aros Smith yeah like I
so told you in when they did the Alum
rocks they were so high they didn't talk
to each other they just lived in the
same house and set what time we'll be
down there at three don't go down there
three from 3: to 5 I got the studio lead
don't go down there from 3 to 5 they
were your addiction takes you to this
place is when you signed up for this
band you just wanted to make records and
make a little bit of money maybe and
play and meet some chicks on the road
and here you are Aeros Smith these guys
were dead for anybody who doesn't know
the Aeros Smith's story they died in
1979 and nobody heard from them till 85
but now you're like Joey so what bands
do that all the time no no no no no no
no I'm talking about at the time they
were the cream of the crop and they fell
apart right in front of your Perry left
the other guy left yeah the Tyler was on
a [__] heroin Bender he couldn't sing
it was a [__] horror show a it was a
horror show and look it somewhere along
the line they released done with mirrors
which I lit on fire that's just a God
awful album I love that record there's
two songs on it I like I remember and I
threw the cassette away I'm like I'll
never listen to this [__] again wow then
the rappers put him on the [__] song
and they blew up the top and they came
back with all that music is it my
favorite orate music no it's not but I'm
happy they got back together was a piece
of my childhood you know we've seen all
these people and you ask yourself the
same story
comedians you know they go to Montreal
they [__] can get the deal they come
here you know this is this moves fast
this is fast moving dog yeah and when
this hits this hits one minute you're
doing Googles and [__] Missouri and
the next minute you're going to call to
do the Toronto Amphitheater it's 62,000
seats 6200 seats I'm sorry yeah and
people going to pay $48 a [__] ticket
for you you're like are you serious yeah
and you're still doing that same [__]
you know you can fall apart
anyway ego has a lot to do with ego has
a [__] big part like you can say uh
drugs but it it's always ego for the
internal Battle of between I was just
reading this thing I couldn't believe it
yesterday but when they when Maiden
first got Bruce
Dickinson and they do number the Beast
record it [__] they shoot to [__]
the biggest and and Steve Harris the
bass player his thing was I'm always in
the front in the middle and Bruce
Dickinson was like third show in like
hey [__] this guy I'm the singer he
started going over and just [__]
smashing him over like you're over there
dude and they and and Steve Harris
admitted they got a number one record
out and he's like I'm thinking of firing
this guy ego because he wanted to be
dead center in the stage it's
unbelievable when I'm reading this like
who's heard of a bass player dead center
you know what I mean as you know I'm an
emotional guy and I get emotional over
dumb [__] sometimes and my internal mind
sometimes you just pissed off for two
days and you go what am I pissed off
about yeah so the other day I go what
the [__] I'm not doing that let me go
buy some albums I go down there I see I
see 10 grade albums that day but two
albums jump out at me synchronicity oh
yeah synchronicity turned my life around
I was in a [__] up spot in 83 that
summer I was a burglar I was going to
college I was working as an electrician
and that album used to sooth me I don't
know what it was that and the pretenders
learning to crawl awesome at that time
and I got regata the Blanc yeah all
right and I got the stones and made in
the shade was one of my favorite of all
time cuz you don't stop the [__]
album just don't stop I like albums that
don't stop sometimes yeah and I'm on my
way home one of my buddies calls me from
Jersey and I and I had we we had been
missing calls for a couple days and I
called them back and he goes where you
coming from and about listen to how P
listen to how much of a child I am when
it comes to music about a week ago his
brother the guy I'm on the phone with
his brother flew out here and met with
another guy from where we're from from
San dieg when they went to those
concerts oh yeah now I grew up in this
kid's shed of music and we used to have
arguments about music and [__] the one
that came out of here was older Anthony
avillo and he posted a picture of Pink
Floyd on Sunday night oh Roger Waters
and it says dogs tremendous and I
[__] get furious if you play dogs
David Gil more better be on that stage
okay if not don't do it you're just
killing me don't [__] do it in front
of me I'll tell you that and I'm driving
I'm thinking about all this [__] on the
way home and and I tell him I go you
know what Steve your [__] brother
went last week and he posted that
picture [__] him and he goes what are
you talking about Joey what are you
talking about I don't I go you know I
can't there's two people I can't stand
the music business I can't stand looking
at them and that's a sting yeah and two
Roger Waters I really can't not stay in
Roger Waters every time I hear him talk
I want to punch him in the [__] mouth
and for years I I liked him I really
liked him and there was one thing I
don't like yeah when he did that thing
on VH1 and they talked about Roy Harper
singing that part oh yeah yeah what song
on money right it's money oh no it's um
uh which one's pink Wish You Were Here
by the way which one pink no it's from
wish you were here so it's got to be
some Melody from that album Shine On You
Crazy Diamond no it's um something it's
the one
uh [__] oh man I was we were just
talking about it you and I and I never
knew that Roy harp is saying that ever
until like three months ago and I was
like wow it something weird they had to
take him out of like he just couldn't
hit it he couldn't hit it an hour yeah
an hour Roger an hour how long is this
gonna take and he couldn't hit it so
they sent him out Roy Harper was next
door he never got paid I get that's Have
a Cigar Have a Cigar yeah yeah by the
way which one's pinky says that in there
right by the way which one's pink Have a
Cigar you're going to go for isn't that
weird because something crazy he
couldn't hit it it sounds just like one
of those guys Roy Harper came in Nails
it and when [__] comes back you know
now they interview him then and now and
he's like uh you know uh right there I
just [__] [__] a whole thing of hate
came over me because I Knew Pink Floyd
just didn't break up because they were
four Geniuses there had to be a [__]
reason yeah and that's he said uh
whatever sang it but till this day I
think I still could have done a better
job you know what [__] you punk [__] you
punk I love Don Felder yeah okay I love
Don Felder there's a big deal with them
and the Eagles that on not the long run
yeah he was going to sing a song on
yes and they took him to lunch and they
take the song with Don Henley and that
cost them their [__] life like but
again you you're not going to pull it
off they eventually let Keith sing Keith
Richard when you hear Keith Richard sing
you want to shoot yourself in the head
you know you're like what the [__] is
this [__] before they make me run
whatever but you know give him the song
he wrote 18 [__] hits yep what's up
Lee you always hear comedians want like
wish they were rock stars in a band does
everyone wish they were the singer cuz I
like or the like cuz I've never I think
everybody wishes they were the star not
necessarily the singer just the main guy
you know that's how it gets into that I
think you know what I mean especially
with drummers because they get such the
short end of the stick they got to
[__] they gotta play drums the
[__] physical and [__] and then at
the end of the day they don't get any
Glory unless you're you know corresponds
or Keith Moon but and and then they they
get cut out of royalties CU they didn't
write the songs and all this [__] that's
why I always get drummers on my podcast
because without a good drummer the band
is it it sucks I'll show you every band
that's great they got it starts with a
great drummer you know that's the bottom
line so you got to [__] keep that guy
happy man because the chemistry is there
it's weird man when you got chemistry of
four guys you can't just go like well us
too we make all the money you know it's
just it's just it's going to blow
up that's crazy I never thought about
that how drummers do get caught up they
do the music business is just as
ferocious gross as any other [__] and
people think that that glamour thing and
you still get robbed somewhere along the
line like there's always a theft years
ago I don't remember like I and I said
this on this show somebody lived in the
building that was on tour with Limp
Biscuit yeah they were opening up for
Limp Biscuit and they were telling me
their story that they don't get paid on
the tour or something the album sale
something just that I sat there and said
what yeah you guys don't get two grand
or something to open up for Lim biscuits
like no we get like prum and something
else we make our records online I don't
[__] know I was like baffled and you
took this deal it's crazy called a 360
deal where the record companies they
figured out well nobody's going to buy
the records anymore so we're not making
any money on these bands so what we got
to do is do a 360 deal which means we
get a a piece of everything in the pie
we get a piece of your touring we get a
piece of your t-shirts we get a piece of
your uh if you're on TV uh we get a
piece of your songwriting we get a piece
of your record sales 360 deal and it's
[__] gross you know it's it's just
insane man but that all trickles down
from people stealing records and
everything you know it just uh the the
big wigs they're not going to give up
their cars and mansions so where do you
think they're going to get the money
they're going to keep digging until they
get the money to keep the the [__]
it's not to keep the lights on it's to
keep the fourth car on and the fifth
house and the you know what I mean it's
it's
insane I
never like I said I that was one part of
me I'm I'm an only child and that [__]
runs deep like psychologically at times
you know I was I always bust Le chops
Lee always says to me well I'm thinking
about my girlfriend moving I go Lee I'm
knowing you from the outside and I I
could tell that you're really personal
guy you don't like people touching your
[__] he's never had a roommate situation
the same since I've met him he never had
a struggle and go to meet Jo I live with
three guys and [__] he'll open his home
to you but I could tell that at the end
of the week as long as he Lee knows
you're going home he's happy like this
ends like in a week you could stay on my
couch
[Music]
w
and